the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi I was just thinking of a story that
came to mind about the woman who went on
vacation and she said you know we went
to Majorca and her friend said to her
where's that and she said how should I
know we flew and today we're going to
fly through matrix algebra in other
words we're going to devote an entire
lecture to the subject called matrix
algebra which is a rather fast pace from
one point of view from another point of
view it's a rather slow pace because
hopefully by this stage in the
development of our course we're pretty
well familiar with what we mean by the
game of mathematics and hence in
particular if we now try to make a
structure out of matrices we should be
in pretty good position to generalize
many of our earlier remarks let me say
at the outset that whereas matrices in
general can be M rows by n columns the
interesting case occurs when m and n are
equal in other words the interesting
case is when a matrix has the same
number of rows as it has columns and
again using as our motivation a system
of equations the easiest way to see this
is that for example if you have a
certain number of equations and a
certain number of unknowns the really
interesting case occurs when you have
just as many equations as you have
unknowns for example if you have more
unknowns than equations
you usually have quite a few degrees of
freedom in other words a far-fetched
case suppose I have one equation with
fifteen unknowns then you see I can pick
14 of the unknowns in general at random
and solve for the fifteenth in terms of
the specific choices of the 14 that I
picked at random on the other hand if I
were to have fifteen equations in just
one unknown the chances are I would have
some contradictions because after all
with only one unknown I could only
impose one condition
and therefore given fifteen conditions
unless they were all equivalent
conditions I might wind up with a
contradiction so in general the easiest
way to summarize this is that when you
have more unknowns than you have
equations you usually get too many
answers to a problem
and if you have more equations than you
have unknowns you usually get too few
answers whereby too few you mean none so
the interesting cases I say is when you
have the same number of unknowns as
equations motivating matrices from this
point of view the game of matrices will
be played in our course as follows we
will let the set S sub n denote the set
of all n by n matrices in other words n
could be 3 and could be four it could be
two it could be five but whatever value
we choose for n for example S sub five
would be what the set of all 5x5
matrices okay so we're just going to
deal with the general n by the way I
should point out that these computations
get kind of sticky
so we will allow street of purposes
usually pick examples with N equals two
or N equals three just so that we can
see what's going on
but the notation that we'll use is that
if the matrix a is a member of S sub n
what does that mean a belongs to S sub n
means that a is an N by n matrix which
usually is written this way and if we
wish to abbreviate it we just write what
the square brackets and a sub IJ inside
the brackets this way now again keep in
mind that to play the any game it's not
enough to have the equipment we have to
have the rules which defines for us how
the terms behave so we're going to
define equality of two matrices as
follows given the two matrices a and B
we will define them to be equal if and
only if entry by entry they happen to be
equal in other words the term in the IJ
throw I throw J column of the first
matrix has to be the same as the term in
the I throw J column of the second
Matrix for all possible values of I and
J and again if you want to motivate why
we choose this kind of a definition even
though definitions do not have to be
defended notice that as soon as you
change some of the coefficients if you
change even one coefficient of an
equation given n equations with n
unknowns as soon as you change one of
the coefficients you've changed the
system of equations there
for these systems to be exactly equal
you want what term by term equality and
correspondingly to add to end by n
matrices in other words to add the
matrix a to the matrix B we define the
rule to be what that the sum of these
two matrix matrices is the matrix C
where each element of C is obtained by
the term by term addition of the
elements in a and B in other words we
add two matrices by adding them entry by
entry in other words we add the two
entries in the first row first column to
obtain the entry in the first row first
column of the sum etc in other words we
add term by term as far as
multiplication is concerned and again
this is the point I was making in the
last lecture and which I like to keep
re-emphasizing because it's very
important one would like to say
something like gee you know it was very
natural to add two matrices term by term
why don't we multiply them term by term
and the answer is certainly you could
have made up a game of matrices in which
the product of two matrices was obtained
by multiplying the matrices term by term
however if we keep in mind what problem
we want matrix multiplication to solve
in other words notice now we are playing
the game of matrices the way the real
life scientist plays games not the way
the abstract mathematician plays games
you see in mathematics what we
essentially say is let's make up the
rules and we'll worry about models that
obey the rules later in real life we say
let's look at a model that we need a
physical realistic model and then based
on the properties that this model has
let's make up the abstract rules that
govern the system and what we saw in the
last lecture was that the sensible
definition of matrix multiplication in
terms of the chain rule was that to
multiply two matrices to get the term in
the I throw J's column you dot the i's
row of the first matrix with the jth
column of the second Matrix and the way
we write that and again this notation
may seem
a little bit heavy to you but all it
does is it states symbolically what we
said in words last time what we're
saying is that the dot the I throw with
the jth column notice that the I throw
is always prefixed by the first
subscript being I whereas the second
subscript K can run the whole gamut from
1 through n in other words the second
subscript can denote any column you want
correspondingly to indicate that you've
stayed in the J's column the row can be
arbitrary and that means again that the
subscript K denoting the row of the B
matrix can run the full gamut from 1 to
N in other words this formal set up here
simply says in mathematical concise
language the statement that we said
verbally before namely to find the a IJ
term and the product dot the I throw of
the first matrix with the J column of
the second Matrix and again I suspect
that the easiest way to see all of these
things is in terms of a specific example
and again the simplest example I can
think of will involve the 2 by 2 case N
equals 2 so by means of illustration let
a be the 2 by 2 matrix all of whose
entries are 1 let B be the 2 by 2 matrix
all of whose entries are 1 except in the
first row second column the entry will
be a - all right now my first claim is
that in terms of our definition of
equality matrix a is unequal to matrix B
why is that well notice that they differ
in the what first row second entry in
other words a sub 1 2 the entry of the a
matrix in the first row second column is
1 whereas the entry of the B matrix in
the first row second column is - don't
say gee they look equal almost because
three out of the fourth match up
remember equality by definition says
what entry by entry 3 out of 4 isn't
good enough it has to be all 4 therefore
this matrix a is not equal
to matrix B how do we add two matrices
well to add them we said that we would
add them entry by entry there for the
first row first column of the sum should
be obtained by adding the first row
first column terms in each matrix
together etc and just going through this
quickly we get what 1 plus 1 is 2 1 plus
2 is 3 1 plus 1 is 2 again 1 plus 1 is
still 2 over here in other words a plus
B in this case would be the 2 by 2
matrix 2 3 2 2
all right now how do we multiply the two
matrices a and B remember what the rules
were for multiplication to multiply a by
B to find the term in the first row
first column we dot the first row of a
with the first column of B that gives us
1 times 1 which is 1 plus 1 times 1
which is also 1 the sum is therefore 2
so the entry in our first row first
column is a tool to find the entry which
turns out to be 3 in the first row
second column how do we do that we dot
what the we want what first row second
column we dot the first row of a with
the second column of B we get 1 times 2
plus 1 times 1 2 plus 1 is 3 etcetera
carrying out the details the matrix a
multiplied by the matrix B in this case
would be the matrix 2 3 in the first row
2 3 in the second row by the way B times
a would involve what writing the matrix
B first followed by the matrix a and
leaving the details for you just to
check out for yourselves notice let me
just do one for you suppose I wanted to
see what was in the first row first
column here I would have to do what dot
the first row of B with the first call
of a the first row of B with the first
column of a that gives me 1 times 1 plus
2 times 1 which is 3 and by the way even
if I went no further here notice that
our that already tells me
in this case at least that a B is
unequal to be a why is that because the
entry in the first row first column of a
B happens to be to the entry in the
first row first column of B a happens to
be three and we've already seen that for
two matrices to be equal they must be
equal entry by entry and they're already
unequal in the entry in the first row
first column so notice by the way that
matrix multiplication need not be
commutative and you see this is a
glaring distinction between matrix
multiplication and numerical
multiplication where when we multiply
two numbers the product does not depend
on the order in which they're written
but when we multiply two matrices our
definition is such that the product does
depend on the order in which they're
written and you might say well isn't
that an awful thing well maybe it is but
notice that once we pick the definition
that we want we have to let the
properties fall where they will and by
the way it is nice to notice and again I
will leave the details out they are in
the notes they will be you'll be checked
on these in the exercises and the like
but the interesting point is that most
of the rules of numerical arithmetic are
obeyed by matrix arithmetic and let me
just go through a few of those with you
just mentioning what they are notice
again the wording here I call these
properties of the game rather than in
terms of our usual game notation the
rules of the game
notice that we sort of refer to things
as being rules when you make up the game
abstractly on the other hand when you
start with a model and tell whether
addition multiplication and equality
means from these definitions you deduce
properties of the system so the
properties of the game of matrices
meaning what the properties based on the
interpretation that we're giving this in
terms of the calculus course the systems
of equations you see there are other
ways of introducing matrices for the
calculus course we elected to do it in
terms of systems of equations but any
rate you can check the following things
out quite easily first
if a and B are any two matrices a plus B
is equal to B plus a and that follows of
course from the fact that when you add
two matrices you add them entry by entry
and the entries happen to be numbers and
the sum of two numbers does not depend
on the order in which you write the
numbers in other words a plus B doesn't
equal B plus a similarly if you add a or
if you add B plus C to a it's the same
thing as if you added C to a plus B in
other words addition of matrices is
associative the answer does not depend
on the sum does not depend on voice
inflection a plus B plus C is the same
as a plus B plus C C again notice how
this obeys the rules of ordinary
arithmetic thirdly if I define the zero
matrix to be the matrix each of whose
entries is zero then I claim that if I
add the zero matrix on to any matrix a
the result must still be the matrix a
and this is also a triviality to check
namely how do you add two matrices you
add them term by term but every term in
the zero matrix is zero and adding zero
on to a number doesn't change the number
consequently if you term by term add
zero on to the entries in a you still
have the entries in a intact
so a plus zero is a and finally the rule
of inverses namely if a is the matrix
each of whose entries we'll call a sub
IJ then if I add minus a onto a the
result will be zero where by minus a I
mean what the matrix each of whose
entries is negative a IJ the reason
being again that when you add two
matrices you add them term by term every
time I add on the negative of a number
to the number itself
I get the zero number consequently every
entry in the sum of a and negative a
will be zero and by definition that's
the zero matrix point I want to mention
is to observe that with the zero matrix
defined as we've defined it and the
negative of a matrix defined as
we have defined it that the rules for
matrix addition are exactly the same
structurally as the rules for numerical
addition and that means that with
respect to addition we cannot
distinguish matrix algebra from
arithmetic algebra numerical algebra in
fact many of the rules of multiplication
for matrices are the same as for
numerical multiplication as well namely
one can show that if you multiply the
matrix a by the product of the matrices
B and C that this is the same as
multiplying a times B by the matrix C
these can be checked by longhand
computation I have you do some of these
things in the exercises similarly one
can prove that matrix multiplication is
distributive that if you multiply a
matrix by the sum of two matrices a
times B plus C is the same as a times B
plus a times C and another rule that's
interesting there is a matrix that plays
the role of a number one and
surprisingly enough it's not the matrix
all of whose entries are one it's the
matrix all of whose entries are one on
the main diagonal and zeros every place
else that may sound surprising you say
Jesus zero matrixes when I had all zeros
why shouldn't the unit matrix be when I
have all ones and the answer is if we
were to multiply two matrices term by
term then the unit matrix would have
been all ones but remember we agreed not
to multiply matrices term by term we
agreed to do what dot the I throw of the
first with the jth column of a second
and if we do that like it or not this is
what the matrix has to look like in
other words let me take the matrix in
the 3x3 case because that's complicated
enough to have you see the overall
picture and simple enough so it doesn't
take pages of computation let me take
the 3x3 matrix which I'll just quickly
write as a b c d e f g h i and multiply
that by 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 you see that's
the matrix that has what ones in the
main diagonal and zeros everyplace else
look what happens when I look for
example for the term in the second row
third column second row third column
look what's going to happen the D
multiplies zero that gives me zero the e
multiplies zero that gives me zero and
the F multiplies one which gives me F in
other words the term in the second row
third column is going to be F which is
exactly what it should be if we claim
that the product matrix is going to be
the same as the first matrix in other
words notice that this set up is such
that you're going to get zeros every
place but where the term in question
comes up and I don't want to go through
that in too much detail for you because
I think that you just play with this
thing you'll see it for yourself let me
do just quickly one more suppose you
wanted the term in the third row second
column you see what's going to happen
here
the G multiplies zero which yields a 0
the H multiplies one which yields an H
and the I multiplies a zero which yields
a zero so the dot product is just going
to be H itself as it should be and so
you see what I'm saying is by my
definition of matrix multiplication if I
define the matrix I sub n to be the
matrix each of whose entries are zero
except on the main diagonal there 1
another way of writing that is that the
nth in fact we can write it this way the
entries let's call this Delta IJ and
what you're saying is that Delta IJ is 0
when I is unequal to J and it's equal to
1 when I equals J and what we're saying
is that if you define I sub n to be that
matrix if you multiply a by I sub n it's
the same as multiplying I sub n by a and
the result will always be a by the way
one of your first objections might be
isn't this redundant why do you have to
write
that a times i sub-n is the same as i
sub-n times a well recall that in our
first example we showed that a times B
did not have to be the same as B times a
in other words note that this remarked
that a times that I sub N equals I sub n
times a is not redundant in general the
product of two matrices depends on the
order in which they're written and that
leads me then into my next subtopic
and that is where is matrix algebra
different from numerical algebra in
other words what are the differences
between matrix algebra and the usual
algebra we've already seen one
difference one difference is that a B
need not equal B a in other words I
could find a and B such that a times B
equals B times a but in general given a
and B at random there is no reason to
presuppose that a times B has to equal B
times a and again there are plenty of
drill exercises on this particular point
the second major difference between this
and numerical arithmetic is the
existence of inverses in other words
given a matrix a which is not the zero
matrix the matrix called a inverse need
not exist now what do you mean by a
inverse the inverse of a number means
the number such that when you multiply
it by that given number you get one
therefore inverse matrices would be what
a inverse would be that matrix such that
when you multiply it by a you get the
identity matrix I sub n in other words
the matrix that has zeros every place
except ones on the main diagonal and
what I'm saying is that whether we like
it or not it turns out that you've given
the matrix a you cannot always solve the
matrix equation a times x equals I sub n
in other words you make what it means in
terms of equations is given n equations
and n unknowns you may not always be
able to invert the equations in other
words given the Y's in terms of the X's
it's not always possible to solve
uniquely for the X's in terms of the Y's
again I'm just trying to give you an
overview here so a more detailed remark
or explanation about what I'm saying
will be in the notes and in the
exercises but the key point is that not
all matrices are invertible and again
the easiest way to see this is to
explicitly go into a 2 by 2 matrix and
take a look let's take here as an
example the 2 by 2 matrix 1 2 2 4 let X
be the matrix X sub 1 1 X sub 1 2 X sub
2 1 X sub 2 2 now I know how to multiply
two matrices I multiply a times X I
obtain the matrix written down over here
X sub 1 1 plus 2 X sub 2 1 2 X 1 1 plus
4 X 2 1 etc I sub to by definition is
the matrix 1 0 0 1 and to say that a sub
x equals I Sub 2 means that this matrix
term by term must be the same as this
matrix in particular if we just focus on
me to get a piece of chalk over here if
we just focus our attention on this
having to be the same as this and this
having to be the same as this this leads
to the fact that X sub 1 1 plus 2 X sub
2 1 has to equal 1 this says that - X
sub 1 1 plus 4 X sub 2 1 has to equal 0
and I claim that right away this shows
that it's impossible for there to be
numbers X 1 1 and X 2 1 that exists
because look at if this if we found two
numbers X sub 1 1 and X sub 2 1 that
obeyed these two equations we would have
proved that 2 equals 0 which as I told
you before is only true for small values
of 0 right now look at if this were true
just multiply both sides of this
equation by 2 it would say what that 2
times X sub 1 1 plus 4 times X sub 2 1
equals 2 but at the same time that same
quantity must equal 0 and since this is
impossible it means that this matrix
does not exist in other words it is
impossible we've just shown it to find
numbers
that I can plug in here such that when I
multiply this matrix by this matrix I
get this matrix that's the best proof
that a inverse need not exist namely
what show one matrix a for which a
inverse doesn't exist that's all you
have to do to show that an inverse
doesn't have to exist just show one case
one counterexample is all it takes all
right so what's the point the point is
we must beware of results which require
a inverse well let's think back to
ordinary arithmetic what results
required the existence of an inverse
well for example in ordinary arithmetic
if the product of two numbers was zero
one of the factors had to be zero and we
proved that by multiplying both sides of
the equation by a inverse well we don't
have inverses necessarily in matrix
algebra so for example in matrix algebra
it's possible that the product of two
matrices gives you the zero matrix yet
neither of the two matrices itself is
the zero matrix or another consequence
of inverse in matrix multiplication it's
possible that a times B can equal a
times C yet a need not be zero nor B
need equal C in other words we can have
a times B equals a times C even though a
is not a zero vector and B is not equal
to C again the beauty of an arithmetic
cost is that we don't have to hand-wave
we can make emotional subjective
statements but we can back them up
simply by showing the existence of
examples so to illustrate my claims here
let me just do this as I say by means of
an example let's take the matrix that we
took an example to let a be the matrix 1
2 2 4 is that the zero matrix no it's
not the zero matrix why because the zero
matrix must have zero entries every
place and this doesn't have zero entries
everyplace let's just out of a hat pull
out the matrix two two minus one minus
one and again without going through
every single detail here if I multiply
this matrix times this matrix the result
is the zero matrix for example just by
way of illustration 1 times 2 is
- two times minus 1 is minus 2 2 plus
minus 2 is 0 that accounts for the 0
here if I check this whole thing through
I will find that every entry here must
be 0 therefore I have what 2 matrices
neither of which is a 0 matrix yet their
product is the zero matrix
alright on the other hand let me now
take the same matrix 1 2 2 4 and
multiply that by another matrix like
pull out of the Hat the one I'm going to
apply the hat is minus 2 minus 6 1 3 and
again just to do a quick check over here
let's check the product in the second
row second column its what 2 times minus
6 is minus 12 4 times 3 is 12 minus 12
plus 12 is 0 in other words this times
this neither matrix here is the zero
matrix
yet the product is the zero matrix and
by the way before I make a further
comment here let me say I didn't really
pull these out of the Hat I leave this
as an exercise for you to do but there
are infinitely many matrices that I can
multiply this matrix by and get the 0
matrix in fact all I have to do is make
sure that the matrix I multiply this by
has the property that the first row is
minus twice the second row and if you
don't know how to do if you don't know
where I get that from all I do is what I
solve again the matrix equation I let X
be the matrix I'm looking for I take 1 2
2 4 multiply it by x equate it to 0 and
see what conditions are imposed on my
coefficients again this is not the point
of our overview here you can do that in
the homework exercises and the reading
material but the key point is what I
have done is what as far as this is
concerned look at these two examples
this matrix times this one is the zero
matrix this times this is the zero
matrix therefore this times this is the
same as this times this notice that this
term equals this term right
and what I'm driving at is is that here
is a case where this is not the zero
matrix
the second factors are not equal to each
other you see this matrix does not equal
this matrix yet when I cancel this
I cannot conclude that this matrix
equals this matrix in other words here I
have what a times B equals a times C yet
a is not the zero matrix and the matrix
B is not equal to the matrix C and so
what have I proven I've proven that it
is not necessarily true that four
matrices when it comes to cancellation
of factors when you're multiplying that
you can take the same liberties that you
can in numerical arithmetic and this is
a very troublesome thing this bothers
people it means that we have to be
particularly careful when we do the
arithmetic of matrices to make sure that
we're dealing with what invertible
matrices what it means again is that if
the system of equations that the matrix
is coding is such that the matrix does
not have an inverse it means that
somehow or other we cannot invert the
system of equations and so what we do in
the study of matrix algebra is we single
out a particularly important subset of
the matrices namely we have a special
interest in those matrices a for which a
inverse exists and because we have that
special interest what we do is we define
a matrix give it a special name if it
has an inverse namely a definition is
what the matrix a is called non singular
provided a inverse exists and what's the
beauty of non singular matrices the
beauty of non singular matrices is that
if you happen to know that you're
dealing with a non singular matrix then
you can take the same arithmetic
liberties that you could with numbers
for example let me just give you an
illustration here suppose I know that a
B equals a C where a B and C of matrices
and I happen to also know that a is
non-singular in other words that a
inverse exists I claim that with this
extra piece of information provided I
know that
is non-singular I claim that from a B
equals AC I could conclude that B equals
C not only can I conclude it but I can
conclude it as a corollary to numerical
arithmetic because remember how do we
prove a numerical arithmetic that you
could have cancellation all it required
was that a number being canceled had to
have an inverse I can pair it the proof
word-for-word namely I'm given that a B
equals AC I say okay I will therefore
multiply both sides of the equation by a
inverse how do I know I can multiply by
a inverse well all I need to know is
that a inverse exists but how do I know
then that a inverse does exist well I
said that a is non-singular and by
definition that means that a inverse
exists so I multiply both sides by a
inverse now I also know that
multiplication is associative that's one
of my rules of the game so I switch the
voice inflection the parentheses in
other words the fact that this is true
means that this is true
see I just switched the voice inflection
but by definition what property does a
inverse have it has the property that a
inverse multiplied by a gives you the
identity matrix I sub n in other words
from this statement I can conclude that
I sub n times B equals I sub n times C
but what properties does I sub n have it
has the property that when it multiplies
any matrix it does not change that
matrix therefore I sub n times B is just
B I sub n times C is just C and I've
concluded what that as a theorem it
follows inescapably in other words that
if a is non-singular then if a B equals
a see B must equal C and this is step by
step the same proof that we use for
numbers except that we had to use what I
sub n instead of 1 if we just recopy
this this is what structurally we cannot
distinguish the proof here from the
proof that we gave in numerical
arithmetic all right now the question
that comes up is how do you determine
whether a matrix is non-singular or not
are there any cute recipes and you know
we've already in this course
for different reasons talked about 2 by
2 determinants and 3 by 3 determinants
determinants get messy when you go up to
higher than 3 by 3 worse than messy they
become deceptive because the obvious
recipes turn out to be false and the
correct recipes turn out to be ones that
are that you rebelled against using
because somehow you're not used to them
and like to believe there's a simpler
way of doing it I am going to save the
precise study of determinants for a
later block of material but I just want
to mention one interesting thing in
terms of determinants and why
determinants come up in the studies of
systems of linear equations and that is
the role of determinants is this and
more details will be supplied in a later
block the matrix a is non-singular if
and only if its determinant is not zero
in other words the existence of a
inverse is equivalent to the fact that
the determinant of the given matrix is
not zero now this is a messy proof so I
will restrict the proof to the case
where N equals two because in the case N
equals two it's rather easy to multiply
these matrices together for example
let's suppose I take the matrix a b c d
now this blue color is the matrix a and
i want to see what should i multiply
that matrix by to get the identity
matrix in other words under what
conditions can i invert the matrix ABCD
well what that means is I want to find X
1 X 2 y 1 y 2 such that when I multiply
these two matrices together I get this
matrix now notice what this leads to
for example this times this is what it's
a X 1 plus B Y 1 but that must equal 1
similarly this times this is C X 1 plus
dy 1 and that must equal this which is 0
and that means what
to find x1 and y1 I have to be able to
solve the system of equations ax 1 plus
B Y 1 equals 1 C X 1 plus D Y 1 equals 0
Oh similarly it also has to be true that
when I multiply the first row by the
second column I have to get 0 the second
row here by the second column here I
have to get 1 that all
so gives me this system of equations
notice by the way that the matrix of
coefficients on both of these two
systems is the same the matrix of
coefficients is what in both cases the
matrix of coefficients is a b c d now
here's the point in order to get a
unique solution here remember both of
these two equations
each of these two equations represents
the equation of a straight line the only
way you can get one and only one
solution is when the straight lines are
not parallel we see if the two straight
lines are parallel if they're different
straight lines there are no
intersections and if they happen to
coincide you have infinitely many
intersections so the only time you're in
trouble here is if these two lines
happen to be parallel algebraically that
says what that the ratio B over a is the
same as the ratio D over C in other
words the unique solvability of these
systems of equations requires only that
B over a be unequal to D over C well
another way of saying that is what that
a times D minus B times C be on equal to
zero but what is ad minus BC ad minus BC
is the determinant of the matrix a B C D
in other words in the two by two case
the matrix is invertible if and only if
its determinant of coefficients is not
zero at least that proves it for the two
by two case let's check it out in a
couple of examples let's go back again
to our old friend from examples two and
three let a be the matrix one two two
for the determinant of coefficients is 1
times 4 which is 4 minus 2 times 2 which
is also 4 4 minus 4 is 0 the determinant
of a is 0 therefore according to our
theorem a is singular by the way I guess
I've slipped here I haven't defined what
singular means I think it's rather
obvious singular is an abbreviation for
non non singular in other words if a
matrix if it's false that the matrix is
non-singular then we call it singular in
other words a
does not have an inverse because its
determinant is 0 and this checks with
our previous result when we showed that
a inverse didn't exist okay let me took
one more example to conclude today's
lesson with let's take the matrix a now
to be the matrix whose first row is 5/4
and whose second row is 7 6 then how do
we find the determinant again it's 5
times 6 which is 30 minus 7 times 4
which is 28 30 minus 28 well it happens
to be 2 but the key factor is that it's
not 0 in other words the determinant of
a is not 0 therefore according to our
general theory a inverse exists and now
we come to why I have to give a second
lecture on this particular topic you see
what I have done now is I have finished
matrix algebra as far as the qualitative
overview is concerned but the major
problem in working with matrices and the
one which I will solve next time is the
following if I'm given a matrix a and I
know somehow or other this determinant
is not 0 or equivalently somebody tells
me that the a inverse exists the
question is knowing that a inverse
exists how do we actually determine the
value of a inverse you see the there's
two problems here one is given a system
of equations say you have n equations
with n unknowns where y1 up to Y n are
expressed in terms of x1 up to xn the
first question is is it possible to
solve for the X's in terms of the Y's
now if the answer to that question is no
we quit but if the answer is yes the
next question and from a practical point
of view this is often crucial the next
question is knowing that we can solve
for the X's in terms of the Y's how do
we actually carry out this computation
and the matrix equivalent is this given
the matrix a a inverse need not exist
but if a inverse does exist how do we
compute it and that will be the subject
of our lecture next time
how to compute a inverse and a corollary
to this will be how is this related to
solutions of systems of n equations and
n unknowns but we'll talk more about
that next time and until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate